who do you think Trump would pick as a
VP uh I I don't know exactly who but
here's here's my general thoughts it'll
either be a charismatic female so
somebody like a Cary lake or a Tulsa
Gabbert or a non-charismatic male Trump
cannot be on stage with another
charismatic male who will steal anything
of the spotlight that's why he chose
Pence to sit in the background that's
why I don't think it'll be ramas Swami
or Tucker Carlson they' both be fine
choices but I think they're off the
table non-charismatic unassuming like
like a Tim Scott M Doug bergo if it's if
it's female Trump trump has no problem
with a with a fiery female
being I think Christy Nome is a good
choice for him VP is not about the
second best it's about who gets Trump a
demographic he doesn't get Chris Christy
gnome can help him get Suburban women
absolutely especially considering what's
going on with Joe Biden economics in
schools you get a middle-aged woman with
Charisma and Trump is is it's it's it's
great he needs that yeah I think I think
chrisy Nome is definitely in the top
three or four